so now I'm saying and I'll doing three
roosting poll one at ten I think that
should keep you far enough away from
heritage of the pooping that poop can go
down here and off the bottom I don't
think they're gonna don't want to go
right on the ground
so it's kind of thing if I went 10 25
they're given 15 inches apart from each
other and then if I went 40 down here
that giving 15 inches from these roots
from each other and it would keep them
16 inches off the ground
kind of curious what you think about
that it's right after the roost holes
for now I'd like to hear your
suggestions in the comments below I can
always move the rooster poles around so
you think that's a good number
let me know you don't let me know why
and what Heights you'd put it at pole
got it
all right now that we got our three
poles it's gonna go ahead take care of
for the research
good job look that put that one up on
this Marx one go ahead put your end up
of pre-drilling
down like that
all right now we're gonna do the water
set up with make an automatic water
again
I have the ball automatic bowl of water
right here to my old chicken coop step
well then use that 55-gallon drum I'll
show you that in a second we're just
gonna set this up a little dirty clean a
lot runs it out but they sent us up low
girls will always have fresh water right
in the bowl one I'm sure the Ducks are
gonna love this we just got this
55-gallon drum that we had set up for
collecting rainwater that was gonna here
you got to stick it's one up high and
one down low the one up high we use the
one that's filled up we hook up a hose
around another 55-gallon drum just had
him continuously in line collecting
rainwater but for this purpose we're
going to use it for automatic water
the reason why I left the stakes high
god no she slipped flipped on we just
clamp it in place
so now the 55-gallon drums all filled up
actually overfilled it this was all
filled up you're just gonna be a little
patient and adjust your float you don't
want to overflow you might have to keep
an eye on it see if the chickens mess
but let us see if it gets disturbed at
all just keep an eye on that and our old
chicken coop we had this set up with the
55-gallon drum and set up with a
rainwater catchment so the chickens
always in the summertime spring all the
chickens always spring summer and fall
had fresh water in that we know how to
fill it up with a hose it's just being a
metal roof over the chicken coop pull
the gutter set right into the 55-gallon
drum they always had a constant supply
of clean fresh water
now we're just about ready for the
heavens put some hay in there we'll let
them get it right
I'm just gonna leave this other deal is
here for them I can move it around and
do whatever they want to do it my thing
coconuts it's still a bunch of crap down
they'll eat all the grass and everything
but
just have fun with all this hey
do extra pills hey I'll just leave them
in there in the coop with the chickens
now comes the fun part with you'll get
the chickens and let them in here and
see what they're gonna do it I'm pretty
excited and interesting to see how the
Ducks are gonna react to the water ball
I'm sure they're gonna love it you make
a mess the dirty water bowl out for a
few minutes but they're gonna have
they're gonna have a blast with it
hopefully the chickens don't mind so
that'll be another video we're getting
the chicks in here and the Ducks and
we'll see how that goes leave in the
comments down below what you guys like
to see for videos give me some ideas
what do you what do you want to see I'm
curious if make these videos to help
people grow to show them what I'm doing
to give them ideas is there anything
you'd like to see anything you're trying
to figure out but you don't know how to
do it even the comments below I'd love
to see and maybe we can make some videos
for you so we'll see you right back here
next time at Alumni acres if you liked
the video give it a thumbs up comment
down below we love reading the comments
we love interact when you guys it's fun
share the video that really helps and
we'll see right back here next time at
Lemna acres if you guys want to see more
of what's going on at one the acres I
post a photo a day on Instagram and once
a week we're doing videos on YouTube go
over to Instagram 1 the acres and follow
us there you can see all the fun photos
we put up